du monde de football match capital ce
soir pour l'équipe de france face à
l'arabie saoudite les français doivent
gagner s'ils veulent être sûrs de se
qualifier pour le second tour
les ventes d'armes dans le monde en
chute libre giat industries annonce un
nouveau plan de restructuration 3 à 4000
suppressions banques
une étape décisive dans la recherche
contre le sida une équipe américaine
découvre le point faible du virus
à long terme cela permettra peut-être la
mise au point d'un médicament ou d'un
max l'hôpital écoles grâce au dévouement
des enseignants des jeunes malades
peuvent suivre presque normalement leurs
études c'est notre enquête de ce soir le
dernier projet d'eric tabarly tabarly va
voir le jour à un nouveau navire école
pour la marine marchande française à la
monsieur bonsoir
l'équipe de france de football joue ce
soir son deuxième match de la coupe du
monde face à l'arabie saoudite les
français qui s'ils veulent être à peu
près certain de leur qualification pour
le deuxième tour doivent obligatoirement
l'emporter ce soir sur la pelouse du
stade de france à saint-denis où ils
viennent d'arriver yann lavoix andré
gerbe
18 heures le bus de l'équipe de france
quitte sa retraite tranquille de pierre
fontaine
le trajet est long plus d'une heure
c'est l'occasion pour les joueurs de
faire le vide avant d'entrer dans
l'arène et de vivre leur histoire face
aux français ce soir une équipe en quête
de rachat en quête d'exploit aussi avec
à sa tête un monsieur monsieur parreira
champion du monde il ya quatre ans avec
le brésil méfiance donc arabie saudite
qui a eu une évolution avec le
changement d'entraîneur changement de
sélectionneur est sûrement très
dangereuse à l'heure actuelle parce que
l'expérience monsieur parreira
automatiquement apportera quelque chose
à cette équipe
donc à nous ne pas nous faire surprendre
l'arabie saoudite s'appuie donc sur des
individualités très technique
les bleus savent qu'ils devront être
concentrés dès le début du match et
imposer leur jeu et leur supposée
supériorité sera vite je crois que dans
l'épidémie pour la minute on se rend
comment comment l'équipe de france
d'aborder le match froid qu'à une
décompression après le match de
l'afrique du sud un petit peu de la part
de tout le monde mais légitime quand on
a une telle pression telle tension
autour de nous mais tout se pousser un
ouf de soulagement de satisfaction
premier comme je peux vous garantir que
de désir on s'est vraiment concentré
dans une heure les gorges pense nous et
car ce soir le vaisseau sera comble
80000 personnes qui attendent une fête
pareille à celle de marseille comme il a
pris l'habitude de le faire c'est à la
dernière minute ou presque que le
sélectionneur aimé jacquet a communiqué
la composition de l'équipe qui jouera ce
soir à saint denis sur place yann lavoix
oui daniel est bien l'équipe qui va
affronter l'arabie saoudite dans
quelques instants vient à peine de nous
parvenir et aimé jacquet nous encore
réservé deux petites surprises
tout d'abord l'entrée en jeu de
boghossian au milieu de terrain à la
place de petits le deuxième changement
regarder il est plus étonnant c'est
l'entrée de diomède en lieu et place de
youri djorkaeff ce qui veut donc dire
que aimé jacquet compte sur diomède pour
déborder sur les ailes essayer de
trouver christophe dugarry au centre une
équipe très offensive
une équipe très portée vers l'attaqué et
c'est plutôt bon signe parce que il est
vrai que dès ce soir l'équipe de france
peut se qualifier pour les huitièmes de
finale et il suffit pour ça d'une
victoire une simple petite victoire mais
avec la manière
la manière est bien permettrait de
prendre un avantage psychologique sur
les futurs adversaires de l'équipe de
france en 8e de finale et pourquoi pas
en quarts de finale et puis s'il y avait
la manière
et bien cela convaincre est
définitivement le public français faire
corps derrière cette équipe de france
un public que l'on attend chaleureux ce
soir on attend 80000 spectateurs pour ce
premier match au stade de france à
premier match de coupe du monde
ici c'est historique merci on la voit
l'adversaire de la france l'arabie
saoudite n'est pas une grande nation de
football au même titre que l'italie
l'espagne le brésil ou la france mais ce
sport passionne les saoudiens notamment
les plus riches émirs du pays qui
financent largement le football et les
footballeurs une équipe saoudienne qui
dépendent directement de la famille
royale christelle bertrand josé
boulesteix loin du brésilien ou de
l'anglais le saoudien est par nature
discret mais quand les rythme s'accélère
il est comme tout le monde
fervents supporters battre la france
voilà un objectif qu'ils affichent
fièrement sur les champs elysées en
arabie saoudite
le football est le sport national dans
le stade de ryad
les matchs sont rythmées par les
applaudissements et les prières une à la
tombée de la nuit une à la mi-temps
disséminés dans la ville les terrains de
fortune sont le point de départ du
football saoudien
pendant les entraînements rien n'échappe
au responsable fédéral qui scrute et
recrutent jouer en équipe nationale est
un privilège c'est devenir un peu plus
proche de la famille royale c'est aussi
être sous les ordres du prince fayçal
ben fahd fils du roi
ce soir là la réception est donnée par
l'ambassadeur d'arabie saoudite en
france presque tous les supporters font
partie de la délégation
c'est le prince qui décide de tout même
du résultat du match
nous avons gagné à la france est et pour
voir le match
les rares soutiens qui n'ont pas été
invités par le prince sont venus par
leurs propres moyens
j'ai fait 7000 kilomètres de ryad à
paris j'ai traversé la grèce et la
turquie
et pour ceux qui habitent en france
voire un peu de leur pays à paris ça
fait toujours un petit quelque chose ce
soir les joueurs saoudien comptent sur
leurs supporters tous leurs supporters
à moins d'une heure maintenant du début
de la rencontre l'ambiance est en train
de monter autour du stade de france à
saint-denis une ambiance bon enfant on
est loin des débordements pour le moins
regrettable du week-end dernier
alexandre kara patrick desmure dernières
touches de couleurs pour les supporters
français
ce soir le grand stade a le teint bleu
blanc rouge et il y à de drôles
d'oiseaux en liberté dernière note aussi
c'est en fanfare que le match se prépare
il y a même des acteurs pour se moquer
de la planète média butin comme
d'habitude il y a aussi les
laissés-pour-compte une place où france
arabie saoudite se négocie autour de
3000 francs alors aulas wade mala france
autour du stade dont nisha pas au
traditionnel concours de pronostics
2 0 pour la france 1 1 but de zidane en
anglais problème rejoindre et s'ils se
sont fait d'apprendre que je crois que
l'arabie saoudite va marque faire un
match nul ou 1 0 pour l'arabie saoudite
et évidemment il ya ceux qui n'ont pas
compris d'abord d'abord d'abord dans les
tribunes le match promet d'être bon
enfant à quelques minutes du coup
d'envoi
saoudiens et français fraternisent le
temps d'une petite danse un match
important pour les français c'est jouer
cet après-midi dans le même groupe à
toulouse le danemark et l'afrique du sud
ont fait match nul 1 partout
l'arbitré a expulsé trois joueurs et
distribué sept cartons jaunes laurent
frédéric bollée pour se galvaniser les
danois ont un secret la musique de
laurine s'est arrêtée mais 20000 vikings
continue de chanter ça ressemble à des
coeurs gallois dans la capitale du rugby
mais c'est bien un hymne au football à
toulouse et dès la 12e minute le
danemark marque
nilsen et le lutteur l'afrique du sud
est encore moins bien parti que contre
la france
les gallois qui multiplie les occasions
avant que les bafana bafana enfin ne se
ressaisissent sur cette action c'est
vraiment lamentable qui est manquée mais
tous finalement est question de patience
début de deuxième mi temps les sud
africains enfin trouvent l'ouverture
buts signés mccarthy le premier pour son
pays dans l'histoire de la coupe du
monde
commence alors un match dans le match
qui aura donc le coût de carton rose
larbitre colombien applique en effet à
la lettre les consignes de sévérité
réclamer aux hommes en noir
moralité à la fin on joue à 9 danois
contredit sud-africain dernière occasion
un tir sur la barre de fortune en
l'occurrence de l'ain fortune un partout
un score qui arrange plutôt le danemark
est plutôt la france si elle gagne ce
soir après la compétition la faire
maintenant des billets achetés mais
jamais parvenue aux acheteurs le
directeur général et l'un de ses
collaborateurs extérieurs de la société
de marketing directement rattachée à la
fédération internationale de football
ont été incarcérés la nuit dernière
après la découverte d'argent et de
billets leur domicile la société y est
celle qui est une entreprise
internationale a demandé un audit sur sa
filiale sa filiale française et dernier
rebondissement en date le vol à paris de
15 mille billets de la coupe du monde et
d'une somme de 3 millions de francs dans
les locaux d'un tour-opérateur amérique
en quête sébastien guibert myriam établi
difficile d'entrer deux jours dans les
bureaux de price port international de
nuit par contre ça semble plus facile
car ce matin les responsables de ce tour
opérateurs auraient découvert leurs
bureaux cambriolé butin annoncé quinze
mille billets de la coupe du monde et
plus de 3 millions de faux cambriolage
qui intervient au moment où la police
s'intéresse de plus près à cette société
qui rachète ici au marché noir les
précieux billets les 17 tours opérateurs
agréés comme prime sport international
ont acheté au cf où plus de 5 % des
billets soit 138 milles unités problème
l on ont promis à leurs clients beaucoup
beaucoup plus autre dérapage du côté de
la fifa la fédération internationale a
fourni 24 % des billets 6 132 milles aux
fédérations nationales destination
prévue club et supporters
mais certains dirigeants au cameroun en
colombie par exemple aurait revendu des
billets au marché noir à l'étrange les
sponsors de la coupe du monde
honteux de leur côté acheté plus de 13%
des billets au cf ou trois cent
cinquante huit mille qu'ils en
redistribuer ensuite gratuitement par
concours ou en cadeaux à leurs clients
amateurs de football
certaines de ces places se vendent
aujourd'hui très bien au marché noir
ysl france partenaire de la fifa avait
elle aussi acheter des places pour ses
clients son directeur général est
aujourd'hui mise en examen soupçonné
d'avoir également participé à ce marché
parallèle dont on ignore encore tout
l'ampleur on procède des colleurs
d'affichés du front national accusé du
meurtre d'un jeune homme d'origine
comorienne c'était à marseille pendant
la campagne présidentielle de 95 un
moment terrible aujourd'hui celui du
témoignage de la petite fille de celui
qui est considéré comme le meurtrier
présumé
pour la seconde fois cette jeune fille
de 16 ans est venu témoigner contre son
grand-père tirer curtet olivier robert
son témoignage avait ébranlé la couronne
à tel point qu'il fut mise en doute et
fait exceptionnel
on a demandé à julie lâché 17 ans la
petite fille du meurtrier présumé
d'ibrahima lit de revenir à la base en
dix minutes elle adressait un tout autre
portrait que celui qui se dessinait
depuis dix jours elle a répété comment
alors qu'elle n'avait que 8 ans son
grand-père l'entraînait à tirer sur des
cibles qu'il baptisait belon
pour tirer sur ces fameux moment je
savais pas que c'était ce que c'était
des moments quand j'étais petit pour moi
c'est un fruit
j'ai su par la suite que des melons
c'étaient les arabes et donc ils
m'emmenaient assistante de tir pour
pouvoir prendre à tirer malheureusement
je serai très bien et est joué il
voulait plus tard voilà j'ai tirent sur
des moments où on disait avec ses
flingues latent de m ce moment là tu
mens pas aujourd'hui julie se dit
soulagée d'avoir pu enfin vider son sac
toute la matinée se sont succédé les
experts psychiatres dans leur bouche
robert lagier est un homme déterminé
mais aussi frustré psychorigide ils le
décrivent comme un militant combattants
c'est le militant au sens fort du terme
dans le mot militants il ya militaire et
il faut se rappeler c'est vrai que son
père était un militaire de carrière pour
lequel il avait une grande admiration
donc il se croyait en état de guerre
vous l'avez jouer ça c'est peut-être que
il
il a tendance à construire des scénarios
dans lesquels il il il est lui même
militant
après le témoignage de sa petite fille
l'image de robert lagier paranoïaque
ordinaire qui tire parce qu'il a peur ne
suffit plus à répondre à toutes les
questions
il faut désormais ajouter aux militants
pro nationale des sentiments racistes
le gouvernement avait adopté hier un
projet de loi constitutionnelle
instaurant l'égalité des sexes en
matière de mandats électoraux et de
fonction dans l'entreprise
coïncidence aujourd'hui le ministre de
l'intérieur a nommé pour la première
fois une femme sous directeur des
affaires économiques et financières de
la police judiciaire mireille
ballestrazzi a déjà derrière elle une
brillante carrière notamment à la tête
du service de répression du trafic des
oeuvres et des objets d'art
les députés de gauche et de droite à
l'exception des écologistes s'apprêtent
à voter une loi allongeant les périodes
de chasse en france la ministre de
l'environnement dominique voynet estime
qu'il ne s'agit là que d'une péripétie
elle n'entend pas démissionner à cause
de cette loi un nouveau renfort pour le
nouveau parti de charles millon la
droite jean françois mancel exclus du
rpr pour ses déclarations en accord avec
le front national a dit qu'il adhérait
au mouvement de charles millon la
réduction des ventes d'armements dans le
monde à ses conséquences en france le
ministre de la défense a confirmé
aujourd'hui un nouveau plan de
restructuration des activités de giat
industries 3 à 4000 suppressions
d'emplois sur un effectif d'un peu plus
de dix mille personnes c'est le
troisième plan social en cinq ans pour
tenter de solder le déficit de
l'entreprise publique d'armement laurent
bailly jean-jacques le garrec le choc le
choc et la colère pour les dix mille
cinq cents salariés de j l industrie ils
viennent d'apprendre que près de 4000
postes seront supprimés entre 2000 et
2002 dans leur entreprise autrement dit
plus du tiers du personnel
alors ce soir à l'usiné de st chamond
dans la loire c'est l'amertume et la
certitude qu'ils dominent cette fois
bien encourageant c'est sûr que c'est
parce que ce qu'on va devenir
c'est grave pour l'avenir de deux yaté
ça met en péril je pense tout où
l'avenir du giat sur les années à venir
c'est alain richard le ministre de la
défense qui a lui même annoncé ce plan
social aujourd'hui une restructuration
la troisième en cinq ans qui touchera
l'ensemble des quatorze site de giat
industries trois usines au moins
seraient totalement menacé de
disparition celle de rennes du mans et
de salbris dans le loiret pour les
syndicats ces suppressions de postes
sont inacceptables c'est le massacre de
entreprise purement et simplement c'est
emile à 15 cents personnes au tapis par
un licenciement sec
c'est quelque chose qui est totalement
inacceptable d'autant plus
qu'aujourd'hui on en est à quatre plans
sociaux a en cours
le cinquième qui se prépare semble-t-il
et c'est quelque chose qu'on va
combattre farouchement le ministre a
beau parler de sureffectifs d'adaptation
inévitable de l'industrie de défense
évoqué les pertes du siat 1/2
de francs des grèves sont bel et bien à
prévoir d'ici le 7 juillet à cette date
matignon tranchera définitivement sur ce
plan social attendant le mois de
novembre on encore le temps voici le
tarif des vignettes 2099 elle affiche
une certaine stabilité d'ensemble à
marnes restera le département le moins
cher
les automobilistes des départements des
ardennes cantal lot et garonne
seine-et-marne et viennent paieront
moins cher en revanche les parisiens
subiront une hausse de plus de 5%
c'est le lot qui reste le département le
plus cher de france pour la vignette 616
francs pour un véhicule de cinq à sept
chevaux c'est la période des examens du
baccalauréat ouvert à tous les jeunes
français même si pour certains la
préparation se fait dans des conditions
plus difficiles à l'hôpital l'éducation
nationale grâce au dévouement de
certains enseignants n'abandonne pas ses
écoliers lycéens ou éco ou simples
écoliers du primaire quel que soit leur
âge donc et qui sont parfois
hospitalisés pour de très longues durées
c'est notre enquête de ce soir valérie
fournioux vwa rocinha
fatigué jean charles est hospitalisé à
l'institut gustave roussy depuis le 8
mai c'est son deuxième cours d'anglais
de la semaine swan et s assit son
objectif passer en cinquième
ne pas perdre ses acquis et ancien
copain qui m'a emmené les cours je les
fais ici avec les profs qui sous marine
pour toi c'est bien ça vous rendre
beaucoup d'ailleurs parce que sont très
contents qu'on vienne les voir
même si quelquefois ils nous envoient
promener les seins et en fait on n'a pas
de blouse blanche et ont fait pas partie
de la famille donc c'est aussi une
échappatoire on fait aussi beaucoup de
diversion pour les faire s'évader
l'évasion par l'éducation
une alchimie bien particulière dans cet
univers de souffrance où ces bénévoles
de nos temps leur savoir que leur
tendresse il faut faire tout ce qu'il
faut pour vaincre la maladie wingles la
tristesse il faut y aller
vous pouvez la vaincre enseignements ne
se posait pas à l'enseignement peut-être
peut-être non je pense que j'ai dressé
dans la nature tout dépend de la maladie
et de la force de caractère de l'enfant
car étudié à l'hôpital est un pari pour
beaucoup dans ce service de l'hôpital
robert debré avec l'appui des preuves de
l'éducation nationale nadia griffé il y
a trois jours va passer ici même son bac
de français
sur le texte ont donc la candide prévert
vous c'est un peu une guerre que vous
menez la contre la maladie
we sing et sa rage et seraient ses
bottes
maintenant c'est la fin de ma maladie
objectif c'est un bat ce combat contre
le temps l'immobilisation à l'hôpital et
pour l'équipe soignante un lien avec
l'extérieur car scolarisé l'enfant reste
comme les autres le travail scolaire et
son domaine réservé où il est ou sera
actif malgré la maladie malgré les
difficultés dues à sa fiabilité
ces défauts de concentration à son
absentéisme et ça c'est quelque chose
que vous regarder de très près bien sûr
puisque c'est pour moi aussi une façon
d'apprécier comment cet enfant réagit
bien vides des traitements qu'il reçoit
aucun lien est rompu avec le collège ou
du lycée l'origine ces profs établiront
une fin du trimestre un bulletin
scolaire car l'enjeu reste primordiale
n'a pas forcément d'indulgence pas fini
on est hospitalisé il retrouve le lycée
comme si l'hôpital c'est loin malgré
tout du lycée dans l'autre sens donc
quand tu y retournes lycée on l'appelle
redemandé d'être performant d'être au
niveau et on la fera pas de cadeau quand
au passage aux examens et jocelyn 12 ans
le sait bien lui qui connaît les
hôpitaux depuis l'âge de 7 ans
hospitalisée régulièrement il n'a jamais
redoublé pour tout le monde dit ne pense
que c'est un daniel malgré des problèmes
de santé
gagner au moins sur un front celui du
savoir pour ces enfants qui ne
comprennent pas quelle injustice a pu
les mener jusqu ici
une équipe américaine n'a peut-être
franchi une étape capitale dans la
recherche contre le sida à long terme
mais il faut le préciser tout de suite
cette découverte peut déboucher sur un
vaccin ou un médicament efficace contre
ce virus jean daniel flaysakier jean
taille il y à des rencontres et des
arrimages qui est de l'humanité a
progressé il y en a d'autres qui sont de
vrais tragédie comme la rencontre entre
les virus vih responsable du sida et les
globules blancs à peine dans la cellule
le virus se sert de la machinerie de son
hôte pour se reproduire jusqu'à 1
milliard d'exemplaires par jour
les trithérapies certes combattre le
virus mais seulement quand il est à
l'intérieur
elles ne peuvent pas l'empêcher de
pénétrer pourtant c'est ce qu'il
faudrait obtenir mais le virus est
diabolique pour entrer dans la cellule
et la parasiter s'accroche
successivement à deux récepteurs en
modifiant permanent son aspect extérieur
si bien que les défenses naturelles de
l'organisme les anticorps le bombarde
120 ce que les chercheurs américains ont
découvert c'est une somme bien cachés et
qui semble ne pas se modifier
c'est pourquoi tous ceux qui travaillent
sur le vaccin sont intéressés par ces
cibles désignées la seule qui vraiment
nous intéresser cette région du virus
donc ça c'est vraiment très important
pour pouvoir maintenant travailler de
façon plus rationnelle sur cette cible
là mais est ce qu'on y arrivera où
est-ce qu'on n'y arrivera pas ça
personne ne peut répondre aujourd'hui à
cette question parce que ce virus est
très spécial parce qu'il a justement
cette extraordinaire capacité à se
protéger à cacher sa zone fragile si
vous voulez on peut encore avoir de
mauvaises surprises
mais peut-être pour une des toutes
premières fois le virus a laissé
entrevoir l'un de ses points les plus
faibles
le 3 juin dernier entre hambourg et
munich une castastrophe ferroviaire
faisait 100 morts et près de 100 blessés
dont 73 demeurent hospitalisés la
commission d' enquête a conclu
officiellement à la rupture d'une roue à
l'origine du déraillement berlin olivier
derrière la bande de roulement d'une
roue du train
anoh d'acier au contact de la voix s'est
brisé à 6 km du lieu de l'accident une
rupture causée par une fissure formée à
l'intérieur de la pièce à dos 100 m de
la gare déchets d un aiguillage a fini
de déstabiliser le convoi la bande de
roulement prises dans l'aiguillé explose
sous le choc elle est projeté à
l'intérieur du premier wagon à 200
kilomètres/heure le troisième wagon se
met en travers leur tu la pile d'un pont
qui s'effondre
le quatrième bague on glisse sur un
talus les 5e et 6e buts contre la pile
de béton les voitures sept à douze se
replie en accordéon comme à mettre à
ruban la version officielle des chemins
de fer allemands ne satisfait pas tout à
fait la justice qui poursuit son enquête
expliquer la cause de cette rupture
intérieur c'est son objectif
en attendant les 59 trains à grande
vitesse de la première génération mise
en circulation en 1991 sont immobilisés
examiné ordre a été donné de changer
toutes les rangs pour combler ce vide
provoqué par cette révision à grande
échelle des trains suisses autrichiens
et français comme le thalys ont été
appelés en renfort
le thalys assure pour une durée
indéterminée
la liaison bonne hambourg le trafic
reste néanmoins très perturbé les trains
qui arrivent à l'heure qu'on figure
d'exception
lionel jospin en amérique le premier
ministre français a entamé son premier
voyage aux etats-unis depuis qu'il est à
matignon une rencontre est prévue
aujourd'hui avec bill clinton et
l'instinct entend mieux se faire
connaître des américains et il avoue
lui-même avoir changé d'avis à propos de
ce pays sur place françoise david
eric de lannion quelques images furtives
qui attesteront que bill clinton a bien
reçu à la maison blanche lionel jospin
deux heures de rencontre dont un
déjeuner et une visite guidée du rose
garden
on a parlé terrorisme et que le mur etc
nucléaire auparavant il y avait eu dans
l'ordre des petits déjeuners
c'est le repas favori des américains le
seul qui prenne stations lionel jospin
en a fait l'expérience ce matin au
capitole de breakfast consécutif avec
des sénateurs avant une réunion de
travail avec le président républicain de
la chambre des représentants discussion
sérieuse quand les deux hommes se
félicite de l'évolution politique en
iran puis le décontracté quand le
premier ministre français refuse de
prendre parti dans la polémique sur la
législation anti tabac
il est non fumeur
c'est en ses craintes si vous même
moment pour hillary clinton ici d'engels
parts dans une école spécialisée pour
enfants en grande difficulté hilary
pratique couramment ce genre d'exercice
c'est une nouveauté pour sylviane
l'école c'était l'avenir le cimetière
d'arlington c'est le passé est un
hommage rendu à ces soldats américains
qui sont morts pour libérer la france et
leur bien-être et spa multiplie
aujourd'hui les entretiens politiques
sénat département d'état banque fédérale
mais ce qui marque sans conteste cette
visite aux etats-unis c'est sa réception
à la maison blanche le premier ministre
français avait déjà rencontré hillary
clinton mais ils ne connaissent pas son
mari et les coudes hillary clinton s'est
dit mme clinton
le président des états unis bref
quelqu'un qui compte ou incident ce nom
à la proche du match de football très
politique entre l'iran et les états unis
washington fait savoir qu'il apprécie
les changements politiques intervenus en
iran des iraniens qui de leur côté ne
repousse pas cette main tendue de
l'amérique 18 ans ou même après la
rupture totale des relations entre les
deux pays jean marc delouze jean
françois renaud sur place le décor n'a
pas changé sur les murs de l'ambassade
américaine à téhéran les vieux slogans
de la révolution sont souvent et cahiers
et rien aujourd'hui n'est venu troubler
la somnolence de ce début de week end
le jeudi vendredi en terre d'islam
mais quand il s'agit d'ouvrir la porte à
l'amérique les points de vue sont
contrastées jeudi que 20 millions
d'iraniens ont voté pour un président en
ouverture est comme moi ils me font
confiance pour conquérir avec la
politique américaine actuelle je ne
crois pas à la normalisation
parce que cette politique est hostile à
l'islam c'est derrière ses grilles que
voilà dix-huit ans 52 diplomates otages
symbolisèrent pendant 444 jours
l'humiliation de l'amérique aujourd'hui
l'ambassade est devenu faculté imams
russe n institution contrôlée par les ex
gardiens de la révolution bras armé des
conservateurs mais qui désormais ne font
plus la loi dans les rues de téhéran
fini les insultes la télévision d'état a
salué aujourd'hui le ton positif je cite
des amériques à mes demandes des signes
concrets de la nouvelle pop volonté de
washington
côté américain à défaut de lever les
sanctions on pourrait libérer les avoirs
iraniens gelés dans les banques
américaines depuis la révolution
une solution que souhaite très fortement
les pétroliers américains désireux de
reprendre pied rapidement en iran
côté iranien on a déjà dit oui aux
échanges culturels oui aux échanges
sportifs mais une reprise officielle des
relations diplomatiques avec téhéran est
une autre paire de manches
le problème reste un grave sujet de
division
entre un pouvoir politique réformiste et
un pouvoir religieux très conservateur
les alliés de l'otan hésitent toujours à
intervenir militairement dans la
province du kosovo où désormais une
faction indépendantiste occupant environ
10 à 20% du territoire c'est justement
dans ces territoires libérés entre
guillemets que se sont rendus nos
envoyés spéciaux
jérôme bunny andris nous sommes au coeur
de la province serbe du kosovo comme un
défi à belgrade
cette salve de l'armée de libération du
kosovo salue la dépouille d'un
combattants tués hier
chaque mort resserre la population
autour de cette guérilla encore jeune
mais qui s'organise sur le cercueil un
drapeau albanais les serbes affirment
que ces hommes se battent en fait pour
une grande albanie
les soldats et les officiers de cette
armée de libération du kosovo sont
particulièrement nerveux en ce moment
car les accrochages sont quotidiens aux
périphéries du territoire qu'ils
contrôlent accrochages avec la police
serbe est même d'après ce qu'ils disent
l'armée yougoslave aux frontières de ce
que les kosovars appel territoires
libérés
les combats ont fait fuir les
populations leur milieu gosses lave est
sur le qui vive à 500 mètres à peine du
poste de contrôle de l'armée de
libération c'est ici que le combattant a
été tué dans le territoire des insurgés
la lutte entre serbes et albanais dure
depuis des siècles cette nouvelle guerre
ne perturbe pas le travail des champs
elle ne fait qu'entretenir la haine
ils ont battu monfils pendant une
semaine pour un pistolet ils me l'ont
rendu parce que marc un mali chez vous
le fief de l'armée de libération chacun
attend chaque jour des nouvelles des
frontières dans l'angoissé permanente
d'une opération serbes contre la
guérilla
l'approvisionnement se fait de nuit on
risque et péril délivre un sco change tu
le verras d'essayer de nous soutirer des
informations sur les hommes et les armes
je n'ai rien dit alors ils m'ont frappé
ils m'ont balancée par terre ils ont
battu le chauffeur pour la seule raison
qu'il est du village de ma vie celle où
jusqu'à quand tiendront-ils au nez à la
barbe des nationalistes serbes qui
tiennent au kosovo comme à la prunelle
de leurs yeux un ancien tortionnaire
commandant d'un camp de concentration
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale
rejoint par son passé 50 ans après les
faits dinko ça kitsch a été extradé
d'argentine vers la croatie où doit
comparaître pour crimes de guerre dès
1941 il faut se souvenir
la croatie s'étaient rangés aux côtés de
l'allemagne nazie et ce croate avait été
nommé à la tête d'un camp à la fin de la
guerre il s'était réfugié en argentine
et ses dernières déclarations indiquent
qu'il ne regrette rien de son passé
j'arrivais avec la police d'argentine
l'a remis hier soir à la police croate
un long voyage
buenos aires francfort en allemagne puis
zagreb en croatie où ce soir le criminel
de guerre couchera en prison dinko
s'acquitte vivait dans cette maison dans
la petite ville de santa teresa à 260 km
au sud de buenos aires mais il ya deux
mois il a donné une interview à la
télévision argentine
reconnaissant qu'il dirigeait le camp de
jass et nos vaches près de zagreb entre
42 et 44 plus de cinq cent mille
personnes ont été assassinées dans ce
camp des juifs des tziganes des serbes
et des croates anti fasciste à l'époque
la croatie était un état indépendant
dirigé par des admirateurs d'hitler
appelé oustachis
le procès de jean cau ça kitsch va être
l'occasion pour la croatie de revoir une
page peu glorieuse du passé surtout pour
les jeunes qui ne sont marquées que par
la guerre des années 90 avec les serbes
mais ce procès va peut-être mettre aussi
en lumière d étrange relation du
président tout show man qui lors d'un
voyage en argentine il ya quatre ans
avait rencontré le criminel de guerre
traditionnelle cérémonie ce soir à paris
au mont valérien chaque 18 juin pour
commémorer l'appel général de gaulle en
juin 1940 autour du chef de l'état ceux
qui furent aux côtés du général de
gaulle
les compagnons de la libération à la fin
de sa vie le dernier d'entre eux viendra
reposer à l'intérieur de cette crypte du
mont valérien un nouvel académicien
français rené rémond a été élu
aujourd'hui historien politologue
professeur d'université à 79 ans il
succède à un autre historien françois
furet dans le courant de la semaine
dernière on apprenait souvenez vous que
les expertises génétiques effectués sur
le corps d'yves montand se révéler
négatif scientifiquement du moins celles
qui prétendait être sa fille ne
l'étaient pas dont aujourd'hui ordre ça
reste choquée par ce verdict et elle
entend bien avec sa mère continuer son
combat en reconnaissance auquel elle
croît toujours valérie gager chagrin et
la sangha depuis j'ai semaine aurore
drossart n'est pratiquement pas sorti
peur des regards moqueurs besoin de
méditer
après la révélation du rapport
d'expertisé qui conclut qu yves montand
ne peut être son père contre cette
vérité scientifique
aurore s'accroche à sa vérité intime
crois que je me serais fait une raison
même si c'était pas la vérité mais
j'avais aucune preuve réelle pour moi et
je me serais fait une raison et j'aurais
acquiescé le fait que c'était pas mon
père mais je peux pas parce que j'ai ma
ressemblance est souvent faim chez pas
les enfants sont là leurs parents quoi
dans une certaine presse la jeune fille
cherche quelques raisons de garder
espoir
avant-hier le journal france soir a
publié les lettres de quatre lecteurs
qui comme elle s'interroge encore
horreur n'imagine pas que sa mère ait pu
lui mentir
pendant près de 20 ans c'est une femme
qui a passé sa vie à se battre dans ce
sens pour que je sois reconnu et moi
personnellement j'ai peur qu'une chose
c'est qu'il lui arrive quelque chose
quand tout ça ce sera terminé parce que
ça va ruiner peut-être ma vie mais une
chose est sûre ce examinera la sienne
est définitivement la cour d'appel de
paris doit rendre son arrêt avant la fin
de l'année en attendant aurore se dit
incapable de tourner la page j'ai besoin
vraiment que d'être libéré de toutes ces
choses de tous ces mensonges et là je
crois que je pourrai enfin enfin
commencer ma vie normale notre nom des
études
mais quand l'instant je ne cherche pas
aurore semble flotter entre raison et
sentiments comment regarder l'avenir en
face avec un passé aussi lourd
la jeune femme n'a que 22 ans la france
rendra à dimanche prochain un hommage
solennel à eric tabarly dont le dernier
rêve qui est déjà un projet a toutes les
chances de se concrétiser le capitaine
de vaisseau tabarly regretté souvent que
la france renonce à son destin maritime
il s'était attaché à la reconstruction
d'un bateau à voile qui servirait de
navire-école à la marine marchande
française vincent de guyenne et pierre
laurent constat c'était un matin de
juillet 1922 sur la côte ouest de la
terre calédonienne 1,5 mais immobile
poussé dans la brume par une forte houle
le voilier français venait de s'échouer
sur la barrière de corail voilà ce qu'il
en reste face à la concurrence des
navires vapeur son armateur a choisi de
l'abandonner tempêtes et cyclones ont
fait le reste
le navire a terminé sa carrière comme
cible d'entraînement pour l'armée
américaine il était pourtant le plus
grand jamais construit au monde 150
mètres de long qui s'appelait france une
telle histoire ne pouvait laisser
insensible le plus célèbre des amoureux
de la mer france a été le plus grand
voilier du monde
bien que en france personne à peu près
ne le sache
et donc c'est un c'est un bateau dont on
peut être fier il fait vraiment partie
de notre patrimoine
et si on pouvait leur faire mieux que ça
serait fantastique
le dernier rêve d'eric tabarly est en
train de prendre forme
ici dans une cité d'argenteuil depuis
quatre ans une association se penche sur
les plans originaux de 1911 pour qu'un
nouveau cinq mâts france prenne la mer
il ne transporterait plus de nickel
comme son prédécesseur mais des
passagers navire école de la marine
marchande
il serait aussi l'ambassadeur du savoir
faire français à travers le monde
eric tabarly travailler sur le même
projet il appelait de ses voeux la
reconstruction du sac ma la france qui
était vain que ces navires préféré avec
l'open bic et nous nous sommes
rencontrés donc en 1994 et j'ai mobilisé
une véritable équipe de travail de
professionnels autour de ce projet de
l'anr à travers le monde des documents
historiques organiseur en france un
chantier d'un million d'heures de
travail trouver un financement de 400
millions de francs
ce ne sont pas là des tâches de marins
tabarly lui a apporté sa caution morale
son expérience et sa connaissance des
grands voiliers il avait navigué
récemment sur le sedov navire école
russe
il était revenu avec un certain nombre
d'impressions techniques précises nous
avait immédiatement transmise en me
disant attention le sedov ce navire est
telle et telle propriété ne sont pas ça
sur la france parce qu'on aura un avis à
qui sera peu performant et c'est la
cloche c'est finalement tout ce qu'il
verra du futur navire une raison de plus
pour ses amis de faire aboutir le projet
véritable élan parce que ce navire doit
maintenant être être réussie pour lui le
5 ma france devrait naviguer en 2001 le
dernier rêve d'eric tabarly sera leur
réalité il ne sera pas à la barre mais
on se souviendra de ces mots compter sur
moi au rang de ceux qui répondent prêt à
manoeuvrer pour que revive france salue
encore la performance du champion
olympique français de saut à la perche
jean galfione hier dans une réunion
d'athlétisme à athènes il a amélioré
vous allez voir son record de france de
3 cm le portant à 5 m 97 très exactement
sur la voie donc des six mètres encore
jamais atteint par un perchiste france
avant de quitter le rappel des
principaux titres de l'actualité de ce
jeudi d'abord les ventes d'armes dans le
monde qui sont en chute libre
conséquence j'ai hâte industries annonce
un nouveau plan de restructuration
trois à quatre mille suppressions
d'emploi assez rapidement
une étape décisive dans la recherche
contre le sida une équipe américaine
découvre le point faible du virus à long
terme cela permettra peut-être la mise
au point d'un médicament ou encore mieux
un pacs dans un instant la météo sophie
davant ensuite le point route de léry
maurice demain 20h vous retrouverez ici
même béatrice schönberg je vous souhaite
un excellent week-end à la nuit bonsoir
bonne soirée sont accrochés